nobody cares about Clark Kent taking on
the Batman I had a really interesting
encounter I was uh buying my kids one
Tuesday afternoon we went to a a costume
shop a Halloween shop there was nobody
in the place the woman proprietor didn't
recognize me or didn't care and not only
that but my son really into Batman
wanted to get a Batman costume so I was
in the Batman aisle and I hear this
voice like hey Ben is that you and I
turn around and it's it's Christian Bale
who's the sweetest guy in the world and
there he and I are standing in the
Batman comic Batman costume row Bruce
Wayne Rachel's told me everything about
you I certainly hope not I said look man
you know you're the best like what do
you think you got any tips and he's
talking to me about going off and doing
the movie and he's like listen make sure
they put a zipper in that suit I
couldn't take a piss for three movies
but mostly if you're going to play
superhero be able to take a piss by
yourself because otherwise it doesn't
feel very superh heroic you know so I
just said have a zipper or something so
he can take care of business himself
whereas I to have somebody take care of
business for me